[Music]
actor Colton Haynes and celebrity
florist Jeff Leatham have tied the knot
in a stunning spectacle Friday night the
two Wed with celebrities like Modern
Family's Sofia Vergara and Jesse Tyler
Ferguson in attendance along with their
respective spouses Joe Manganiello and
Justin Makita also on the guest list
Lisa Rinna and Colt loos American Horror
Story co-stars Leslie Grossman Cheyenne
Jackson Billie lourd
and guess who married the pair none
other than kris jenner herself the
wedding went down at the Four Seasons
Hotel in Palm Springs
of course since Liam is one of the most
sought-after floral designers having
worked with Oprah
Chelsea Clinton and more the flowers
were over the top
guests could not stop sharing videos and
photos to Instagram the walkway the
table settings it was all gorgeous
you can't imagine oh you outdid yourself
the champagne was flowing and Lisa man
Haynes even did a few outfit changes
posing in both white tuxes and sparkling
in these black ensembles for their first
dance and cake-cutting plus their moves
clearly inspired the guests the dance
floor at this wedding was lit sofia and
joe cut a rug as did Jessie and Justin
Congrats to the happy couple
you